et la primaire ce sera l'objet du bureau
politique des républicains demain séance
qui s'annonce agitée entre ceux qui
veulent une primaire ouverte et ceux qui
veulent une primaire fermée ceux qui
n'en veulent carrément pas alors faut-il
recommencer une grande primaire comme en
2016 la même question se pose aussi à
gauche en ce moment est ce une opération
risquée pour les partis politiques c'est
l'objet de notre décryptage
et pour en parler nous sommes avec alain
houpert sénateur a l'air de côte-d'or on
serait de remettre un présent au bureau
politique et d'un père un des
républicains bonsoir à vous et à vos
côtés yves d'amécourt des mes cours par
d'anciens élèves
vous êtes aujourd'hui le porte parole
national du mouvement de la ruralité
merci d'être avec nous avec nos
également alexis poulain notre
éditorialiste bonsoir alexis alors pour
la première fois dans une tribune ce
soir au figaro valérie pécresse laurent
wauquiez et hervé morin bruno retailleau
demandent ensemble à une primaire
ouverte de la droite et du centre dans
une tribune donc publié ce soir votre
réaction à la houppe r c'est une bonne
chose pour vous ce mérite débat et on a
sur les primaires une très mauvaise
expérience
souvenez-vous de 2017 et les primaires
c'est c'est quelque chose d'anglo saxons
c'est pas dans notre adn et surtout
républicains c'est une politique
spectacle n'atterrit téléréalité et
celui qui sort vainqueur des primaires
sort affaiblie je dirais cramer parce
qu'il a sorti tous ces arguments pour la
présidentielle et il va lors de la
présidentielle se continuer à débattre
avec les mêmes phrases avec les mêmes
arguments au risque de lasser des
électeurs et nous sommes dans une
période difficile
je pense que ce serait indécent de faire
de la politique
réalité de faire de faire la roue de
faire le paon pendant
pendant sept ans et demi pendant sept 7
france vie pour ses 38 d une période
difficile
chaque week-end on nous annonce le en
général olivier devron nous annoncent
eux une semaine catastrophique
nous venons d'assister à adé des projets
de lois liberticides le la france est
dans une période dramatique
je pense qu'il faut comme le disait
monsieur bertrand être dans une stature
gaullienne et je pense qu'on peut
décider entre nous de savoir qui va être
le candidat à la présidentielle parce
que la présidentielle ces deux tours et
il faut être
il est pas de triangulaire il faut être
au deuxième tour il ya trois parties qui
sont capables de mettre un candidat au
deuxième tour il ya le col parti
présidentiel emmanuel macron il ya le
front national
le rassemblement national il y à la
droite et le centre
et je n'imagine pas emmanuel macron son
parti et le rassemblement national faire
une primaire donc nous seront
automatiquement à séville face à ces
deux candidats il faut que le candidat
de la droite et du centre et les
dernières élections le montrer la france
est à droite
il faut que ce que notre candidat soit
désigné soit le deuxième tour alors
allez on perd on aimerait bien pour vous
que ça soit aussi simple enfin
s'assemble
en tout cas mal engagée sur le point de
la santé cité à cette heure puisque
xavier bertrand lui on rappelle qu'il a
claqué la porte du parti rpt en 2017
mais il n'empêche c'est un candidat de
droite
il n'en veut pas de cette primaire il a
dit d'ores et déjà qu'il n'irait pas
xavier bertrand a d'ailleurs qui
enregistre aujourd'hui même alors que
cette tribune est publiée
un soutien celui de numéro deux des
républicains guillaume pelletier vice
président délégué on écoute je considère
que nous avons désormais un candidat
naturel
xavier bertrand est le mieux placé
d'entre nous le seul capable de battre
emmanuel macron est de faire gagner la
droite il daniel coureau c'est quoi ce
soir cette tribune c'est une manière de
mettre la pression sur xavier bertrand
oh bah c'est tout simplement des gens
qui s'inquiètent
on est à huit mois l'élection
présidentielle et les républicains qui
est le parti leader de la droite et du
centre n'a toujours pas choisi de
méthodes de départage alors que ses
statuts prévoient une primaire ouverte
donc en fait et républicains depuis 2010
est avait deux missions la première
c'était de construire un projet
d'alternance et la deuxième c'était
d'organiser une méthode de départage ces
deux missions elles n'ont pas été menées
à bien et on a même choisi au moment où
on a renouvelé le président des
républicains
un président en lui demandant de
s'engager à ne pas être candidat à quoi
que ce soit alors que dans l'esprit du
parti c'était le président du parti qui
était le candidat naturel est donc là on
a un président de parti qui est le nom
candidat naturel et donc rien n'a été
fait pour choisir un candidat
et aujourd'hui on nous propose un
sondage auprès de quinze mille personnes
pour choisir le candidat de la droite et
du centre
autant vous dire que ça ressemble pas à
grand chose puisque quand on regarde les
sondages qui ont eu lieu avant les
élections régionales
les résultats ont été tout autre que
ceux annoncés par les sondages et quand
on se souvient des rêves et des sondages
avant la primaire de 2016 jusqu'à la
veille le sondage qui a eu lieu la
veille de la primaire
donner les trois candidats ex-aequo
alors qu'en fait il ya eu des
différences énormes entre les entre les
trois candidats de la primaire
donc tout ça ne ressemble à rien donc
jean leonetti a été investie d'une
mission qui est de proposer une solution
de départage je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
ya deux solutions de départage qui sont
sur la table soit une primaire ouverte
je crois que la primaire fermée c'est
fermé puisque toute façon les dirigeants
même des républicains choisissent des
candidats à l'extérieur des républicains
de toute façon dans une logique ouverte
et l'autre solution qui avait été abordé
par jean leonetti c'était de consulter
cent cinquante mille élus locaux voilà
donc je pense que mardi il y aura un
choix entre ces deux solutions
mais par contre il faut aller vite
puisque pour pouvoir présenter un
candidat l'année prochaine il faut qu'il
y ait un débat l'intérêt d'un choix
entre plusieurs candidats c'est de
pouvoir les entendre sur leurs projets
et donc il faut pouvoir les entendre sur
leurs projets et comme christian jacob
dit le 30 septembre on se mettra
d'accord sur une méthode pour choisir
début novembre
c'est pas sérieux on est en train de
parler de l'avenir de la france
on a assez reproché au président
emmanuel macron d'être dans
l'improvisation permanente et son
prédécesseur avant lui c'est pas pour
choisir un candidat qui n'aura pas de
projet et sans avoir travaillé sur le
fond comme l'avaient fait les candidats
à la primaire de 2016
on avait eu le droit en 2016 un vrai
débat sur le fond qui avait passionné
les français et qui avait fait que 4
millions de français s'étaient rendus
aux urnes pour choisir le candidat de la
droite et du centre
l'autre vertus que je vois moi à une
élection primaire c'est que dans une
élection primaire ne votent que les gens
qui seront code se reconnaissent dans
les valeurs de la droite et du centre
et donc le débat a bien lieu sur un
programme de droite alors que quand on
envoie quelqu'un sans connaître son
projet finalement il va nous proposer un
programme centriste et on va de nouveau
repartir dans un bain dans un nom mandat
sans régler les problèmes sans proposer
les vraies solutions sont proposées
finalement ce qu'attendent notre ce
qu'attend notre électorat
alexis poulain cette droite est-ce
qu'elle a intérêt à ces primaires où la
machine à perdre
ça y est les lancers autant publier
directement l'acte de décès faire la
nécrologie des parties particulièrement
on a des républicains s'il décide en
corse de partir sur une primaire ouverte
clairement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que ce sont des partis qui sont
incapables de se renouveler d'aller
chercher des militants d'aller aussi
animer un débat démocratique interne qui
va faire qu'il ya d'émotion qu'il ya des
projets qu'il ya des hommes et des
femmes aussi qu'ils sortent qui se
démarque parce qu'ils sont porteurs de
projets parce qu'ils ont su fédérer en
interne
allez dire que les sondages et des
primaires ouvertes c'est à dire quoi une
échalote va faire qu'on va sélectionner
un candidat parce qu'il sera finalement
le plus tendance le plus hype eu à un
moment donné c'est ridicule on arrête la
politique en réalité qu'on accepte que
la politique est devenue un spectacle et
qu'il n'y a plus de débat d'idées qu'il
n'ya plus réellement quelqu'un qui porte
un projet pour ce pays qui va mal un
monsieur ou pearl à la betty et je
partage tout à fait son analyse il n'est
plus temps de tergiverser de faire
semblant
aujourd'hui je crois que les nombreux
électeurs des nombreux électeurs qui se
déplacent parce que rien l'abstention
qui fait que les gens ne votent plus et
pourquoi parce que justement la
politique n'intéresse plus parce que la
politique ne fait plus de politique
elle fait du spectacle au mieux et sinon
elle fait du marketing et de la vente à
la découpe du pays c'est ce que fait
emmanuel macron depuis maintenant quatre
ans
donc aujourd'hui si que les républicains
veulent un candidat eh bien ça se
discute en interne ça se discute aussi
avec de nombreux militants ça fait que
la démocratie est vivante parce que les
partis sont vivants donc ce qui
m'inquiète moi aujourd'hui c'est de voir
qu'on est seulement à huit mois d'une
élection majeure et qu'aucun parti n'a
organisé et les républicains pas plus
qu'un autre
cette démocratie interne cette recherche
des militants
ce labourage du terrain qu'est ce qui
fait qu'un parti est vivant c'est qu'il
est vivant dans les territoires qu'ils
sentent qu'il est présent avec de
nombreux élus dans les villes dans les
régions dans les départements ce n'est
pas le cas dans marche n'est pas le cas
du rassemblement national
et pourtant les sondages ne pouvant
d'une affiche en 2022 entre emmanuel
macron et marine le pen tous deux n'ont
aucun parti ils ont un parti médiatique
les républicains ont une chance c'est un
parti qui existe que les français
connaissent ils ont un rapport concret
avec des élus de ce bord là
quotidiennement que ce soit à tous
niveau de la république donc il ya la
carte à jouer importante et on a
l'impression qu'il veut le faire en fait
est à la mode c'est à dire faire un
parti médiatique et donc trouver quel
sera le candidat le plus médiatique
c'est une erreur une grave erreur qui
pourrait conduire à une défaite évidente
parce que quelle sera la différence
entre un candidat médiatique aura le
même projet puisqu'il ya une programme
qu emmanuel macron qui va inventer un
projet sans doute deux mois avant
l'échéance puisque à l'avancé il sera
occupé par la présidence de l'union
européenne
d'autant que l'un d'entre eux qui est un
homme de terrain alors comme certains
autres évidemment à laurent wauquiez
valérie pécresse notamment mais enfin
xavier bertrand lui il semble tenir la
corde
il veut d'amécourt nous citer un sondage
tout à l'heure on va jeter un oeil parce
que même si les sondages se trompent
souvent un surtout en ce moment ils
peuvent quand même être intéressant
regardez d'après l'institut de sondages
ifop
xavier bertrand pourrait largement
battre marine le pen et même emmanuel
macron chiffres d'intentions de vote au
deuxième tour on voit clairement que
xavier bertrand l'emporterait 1 4 point
de plus que manuel macro et la deuxième
tour dans le cas d'un xavier bertrand le
pen
xavier bertrand écraserait marine le pen
clairement alain houpert ça veut dire
quelque chose ce type de sondage pour
vous vous ne les prenez pas au sérieux
la droite aujourd'hui n'at-elle pas un
candidat naturel comme le dit guillaume
pelletier concernant les sondages comme
l'a dit monsieur poulin on a vu ce que
ça donnait comme vous l'avez dit avec
les élections régionales
ils se sont complètement trompés après
son élection régionale aussi fait des
pressions mais les sondages disaient que
nous allions avoir trois régions sous la
gouvernance du front national c'est
assez
ça a été un échec pour le front national
ça a été un échec pour la république en
marche
la france est à droite et au centre il
nous faut un candidat de la droite et du
centre et nous sommes capables de
décider nous mêmes comme l'a dit
monsieur poulat entre nous comme on dit
à la campagne on lave son linge sale en
famille
on discute en famille on est capable de
décider nous mêmes quel sera le candidat
ça peut être monsieur bertrand s'appelle
monsieur wauquiez ça peut être madame
pécresse
peut être monsieur s ça peut être
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes et nous
avons nous avons un homme un homme de
stature qui s'appelle nicolas sarkozy
qu'on devrait consulter pour qu'il voie
les candidats qui les auditionne et puis
je pense que nicolas sarkozy sera la
personne a auditionné pour qu on puisse
débattre entre nous en famille et
décider entre nous en famille que sera
le candidat à la présidentielle le
candidat de la droite et du centre
alors à défaut de nicolas sarkozy à l'un
de ses proches ans s'est déjà exprimé
sur le sujet brice hortefeux le député
européen a l'air proche de l'ancien
président il n'est pas d'ailleurs du
tour sur la ligne de guillaume pelletier
côté l'élection présidentielle ne doit
pas être une démarche solitaire mais un
élan solidaire
il n'y a pas de candidat naturel il faut
qu'il y ait un système pour choisir et
qu'on se rassemble
je souhaite que xavier bertrand
participent au processus de sélection
car il n'y a pas de candidat
autoproclamé il d'amécourt vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic de brice
hortefeux l'élection présidentielle ne
doit pas être une démarche solidaire
solitaire par don solidaire et devrait
l'être justement lapsus révélateur
emmanuel macron était bien solitaire et
ça lui a plutôt réussi au départ en tout
cas en fait emmanuel macron a été élu
non pas à cause des primaires de la
droite et de la gauche il a été élu à
cause de deux du buzz médiatique a été
organisée autour de françois fillon et
qui a finalement empêché françois fillon
d'être qualifiés au deuxième tour parce
que tous les sondages d'aujourd'hui sont
très bien il donne
xavier bertrand gagnant au 2e tour ils
donnent tous les candidats gagnants au
deuxième tour le problème c'est pas
tellement d'être gagnant au 2e tour
c'est d'être qualifié au deuxième tour
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a le souci
parce que si on avait pas d'inquiétude
sur la qualification de l'amener au
candidat le premier tour servirait de
primaires comme ça a été le cas à
l'époque entre entre chaban et giscard
d'estaing comme ça a été le cas pour
michel debré est comme ça a été le cas
aussi entre raymond barre et jacques
chirac comme ça a été le cas entre
edouard balladur et jacques chirac
le problème c'est que le premier tour ne
sert plus aujourd'hui de deux primaires
puisque il y a trois partis qui sont
capacité d'aller au second tour et donc
il faut trouver une solution alors vous
savez quand on élit le pape ont réuni
les cardinaux et puis on fait un
conclave et puis à la fin personne ne
conteste l'élection du pape
moi ce que je reproche à notre famille
politique c'est que on est à huit mois
de l'élection présidentielle et rien n'a
été organisé et donc on est en train
d'appliquer le précepte d'henri queuille
qui était un ministre de la cohésion de
la quatrième république qui disait je ne
connais pas de problème qu'une absence
de solution ne finisse par résoudre mais
le problème c'est que c'est pas comme ça
qu'on gagne une élection il faut
s'organiser
on a besoin d'avoir un projet un projet
solide un agenda de gouvernement on
apprend on a des gens qui sont très
intéressés par cette élection d'ailleurs
qui sont intéressés beaucoup plus par
élection présidentielle que par
élections régionales parce que quand on
questionne les gens il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont pas venus voter aux
élections régionales mais qu'ils disent
mais qui nous ont dit on viendra voter
aux élections présidentielles donc
méfions nous des résultats des élections
régionales et n'en faisons pas une une
prévision de l'élection présidentielle à
la question de la primaire de mise à
droite mais également à gauche puisqu'il
n'y a pas de de grandes primaires
ouvertes pour désigner un candidat
commun à la gauche aux primaires a
annoncé d'ailleurs pour les écolos un
projet serait en préparation au ps
clairement alexis poulain c'est un sujet
sensible secteur de deux divisions la
mise en place d'une primaire dans un
parti politique
oui évidemment enfin regarder et mal
macron réussi son coup parce qu'il
refuse tout primaire finalement et à
gauche et à droite puisque à l'époque
qu'il était demi de gauche ni de droite
donc c'est très facile de dire à partir
du moment où on a
une vague médiatique qui vous pousse
très facilement vers vers l'élection
présidentielle de s'affranchir
finalement de cette démocratie interne
résultat des courses il la démocratie a
souffert regardez la façon dont a été
traité le parlement france sous ce
quinquennat
donc il est important aussi que les
projets politiques prime d'abord sur sur
les personnalités sur la guerre des ego
celle qu'on veut vendre et à gauche
c'est clairement ça aujourd'hui on voit
bien yannick jadot contrarien d'aller à
une primaire à gauche jean luc mélenchon
qui a décidé d'y aller seul de toute
façon et puis suivra qui veut derrière
le leader de la france insoumise et puis
au ps on attend de voir alors carole
delga vient de sortir parce qu'elle a
gagné deux régions mais ça ne veut rien
dire en réalité le ps à bien des idées
sur de potentiels candidats mais à huit
mois d'une présidentielle encore une
fois je trouve que c'est un peu tard
pour s'organiser quand on est un grand
parti structuré et c'est cette
précipitation cette précipitation qui
joue d'abord le jeu du temps médiatique
plutôt que je ne tends politique que je
critique parce que ce que veulent les
français je crois
et pourquoi ils se désintéressent
finalement des désirs mais c'était taux
d'abstention important devrait dire une
chose c'est qu'ils attendent des
politiques de rupture c'est ça suffit
cette politique finalement qui mêle
macron incarne absolument qui est celle
qui n'a pas changé un d'essayer de faire
des réformes qui n'aboutit jamais de
continuer dans une intégration
européenne perpétuel et finalement de ne
rien changer pour tout changer non je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya des vrais
débats
d'ailleurs cette candidature surprise
qui n'en est pas une puisque il ne s'est
pas déclarée mais génération et nous qui
colle des affiches pour l'eczéma ou
qu'ils essayent de pousser le débat
justement vers des sujets plus clivants
plus délicat c'est ça qui attend les
français un vrai débat de fond sur
qu'est ce qu'on attend
qu'est-ce qui va attendre ce pays la
france dans les cinq les 10 prochaines
années si on ne fait rien si on ne
change rien alors rien ne va changer
évidemment
or est-ce qu'on veut continuer
l'intégration européenne est-ce qu'on
veut continuer les politiques
migratoires telles qu'elles sont est-ce
qu'on veut continuer les politiques de
l'emploi subventionné ou pas alors que
ça ne fonctionne pas est ce que l'on
veut continuer de faire semblant
sur l'insécurité la sécurité avec des
politiques là encore qui sont des
rustines ou des politiques médiatiques
dont je crois qu'aujourd'hui les sujets
importants ne sont pas abordés ils sont
toujours évité de manière tabou haendel
macro est passé maître en la matière
puisqu'il dit tout et son contraire
d'une semaine sur l'autre donc c'est
très facile mais
c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux de
faire ça en réalité aujourd'hui on
demande à responsables politiques de se
positionner peut dire ce qu'il pense et
de dire ce qu'il va faire pour résoudre
les problèmes des français donc c'est ça
si une primaire il doit avoir alors
elles doivent être des primaires
programmatique d'idées de débats d'idées
et surtout de projets de concret c'est à
dire voilà ce que je vais proposer ses
services et françois fillon avec c'était
le seul à avoir un vrai programme écrit
concertée il ya l'avenir en commun
également de jean luc mélenchon ou là
des gens travaillent sur un programme
aujourd'hui on a l'impression que c'est
j'y vais parce que ballet français même
bien donc je vais y aller non c'est pas
ça la politique et c'est certainement
parce que les français at on perd le mot
de la fin pour vous puisque on le disait
en ce début de débat vous serez demain
matin présence au bureau politique des
républicains vous allez taper du poing
sur la table à votre niveau
qu'est ce que vous allez leur dire je
veux dire que l'élection présidentielle
le principe de condorcet je préfère un
terrain intel et il ya deux candidats au
deuxième tour
c'est pas une triangulaire ces deux
candidats il y aura le front national et
cheveux que le candidat contre le front
national
ce soit un candidat de la droite et du
centre est pas emmanuel macron parce que
nous nous battons depuis quatre ans
contre emmanuel macron il serait injuste
comme l'a dit monsieur poulin qu'il soit
à nouveau président de la république
merci en tout cas à tous les trois alain
houpert avec six poulains yves
d'amécourt d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte et france les suit donc
demain on en saura peut-être un peu plus
après cette réunion et ce bureau
politique merci à vous